Andrew Horng, Writer/Director:
Nowadays, there are competitions out there
that challenge you to make a short film over
the course of just one weekend.They’re
a really fun way to gain experience, network,
and create a film quickly.Very quickly.
Last year, I entered my first “timed”
competition, and the short film I wrote placed
1st out of 58 total films.I met Marcia
Gay Harden, I got into Variety, and I was
even invited by my team to compete for a second
and third time, writing films that ranked
among the very best.Today, I’m gonna
teach you what I’ve learned from my experiences
to bypass the competition and get you into
the cream of the crop.
KNOWING YOUR GENRE
The first thing you gotta know is… for these
challenges, the shorts are due on Sunday,
which means you really only have Friday to
work on the story and deliver a script.In
addition to that, the competition wants to
make sure that you don’t start any earlier,
so they give you a specific list of requirements
on Friday that must be present in your film.
My first piece of advice is to split these
requirements up.Ignore minor requirements
like props or dialogue, and start with the
one that matters the most: genre.Genre
is going to be your compass, pointing your
story in the right direction.You need
to deconstruct that genre, and figure out
what that genre is really all about on a sub-atomic
level.
For example, we were given the fantasy genre
for our second film “Crystal’s Ball.”After
researching examples online, I noticed that
many fantasy stories follow a similar structure.A
character has some sort of pain and enters
a sort of fantasy land to escape that pain.But
it’s not all peaches and creme there, and
the character eventually returns to the real
world with a new outlook from the entire experience.And
that’s what we ended up doing.We told
a story about a grieving daughter that uses
a crystal ball to reunite with her dead father.But
their reunion is not all peaches and creme.And
near the end of the film, she leaves and is
a tad different from where she started.
ACTORS & LOCATIONS
After breaking down your genre into its most
basic form, you should then consider the two
big assets you’ll be working with: actors
and location.Because time was of the essence
for our films, both the actors and the locations
were already set each time before the story
was even conceived.But that’s actually
okay since those two factors, along with an
understanding of the genre, are a great launching
point for brainstorming.
My first suggestion for generating ideas is
to zero in on conflict.Conflict is the
life blood of any story, even a short one
told in just a few minutes.What might
help you get in this conflict mindset is to
just casually think about what a potential
problem could be when you factor in both your
actors and your location.And then after
that, a potential solution.When you’ve
come up with some possibilities, I’d suggest
you start your story with the problem that
excites you the most.
That being said, my second suggestion during
this stage is to keep it simple.You don’t
have hours to tell your story, only minutes.And
you don’t have much time to write it out
either.You can be more detail-oriented
later in the process, but it probably won’t
do you any favors to do so at the very start.What
may help with simplicity is to think of your
story in threes.Take a step back, look
at the big picture, and try to describe your
story’s beginning, middle, and end in the
most simplistic way.
For example, before writing our first film
“Check Mate” we had a house as our location
and four actors cast already.So, zeroing
in on the conflict, the problem that was the
most exciting was about the house having a
vacancy, and two of our actors fighting over
it.Meanwhile, the other two actors became
the ones who already lived there.So then,
expanding that premise into threes… the
two actors meet at the house in the beginning
of the story… they fight over the vacancy
in the middle… and then they quickly become
friends and decide to room together by the
end.They meet.They fight.They
become friends.Simple.
TREATMENT STAGE
When you’ve figured out the simple beginning,
middle, and end of your story, you could just
jump into writing the first draft of the script.Or,
what I recommend, is to take another writing
step in between and write out a brief synopsis
of your story in just a couple of paragraphs.By
doing so, it gives you another opportunity
to rewrite your story in a new format and
do so quickly.
Also, a brief synopsis is going to be a tad
more detailed, so here you’re going to want
to add in the “lesser” requirements from
the competition.Requirements like what
props to put in or what dialogue to say will
be easier to plug into your story, now that
you already have the “backbone” for your
story figured out.
If you’re with another writer or the director
at this stage, this is your chance to pitch
them with your synopsis and get them on board
with your story before you flesh it out in
script format.Especially if you or someone
else is not quite sold on the idea yet.Here,
you can get feedback regarding what you need
to improve on, or you can get confidence with
what’s working with your story.
WRITE IT QUICKLY
With all that very loose planning done, and
all your thinking power focused on what assets
you have and what requirements you need to
check off, you can now focus on writing your
story out in script format.I use Final
Draft, but really any screenwriting software
out there should help you create your final
version as quickly as possible.
For this last step, I’d suggest pulling
up your synopsis, and then quickly writing
out a script version of it that you’ll probably
think is bad.Also, I would restrain yourself
from making any edits to it until you’ve
finished writing this bad draft.But keep
in mind, even though you’ve already done
a bunch of planning, this is still your very
first draft of the script.It’s supposed
to be rough and unpolished, so don’t beat
yourself up over the quality.Just focus
on converting your synopsis into a bad draft
first, and then (after you’re done with
that step) look at it with a critical eye
and make some edits for your final draft.
EASTERSEALS DISABILITY FILM CHALLENGE
So my first and third films I did for competition
were for the Easterseals Disability Film Challenge,
which was amazing to be a part of.Disability
is very much underrepresented and misrepresented
in the media, and being a part of the challenge
helped to move the needle when it came to
that.
The competition welcomes all filmmakers who
are down with that cause and down to make
something really quick.So now that I’ve
given you some tips on how to write for a
timed competition, I hope you’ll consider
joining that one and making an impact as well.
If you want to check it out, or any of the
films, please see the links in the description
below.Good luck, and I’ll see you next
time on Film Courage.